Hi.
I'm Meryam Bukhari, a student in
the 2016 class of the MIT Sloan
MBA program.
I'm 26 years old
and a millennial.
What do young workers--
millennials-- today want
from their jobs and careers?
And how do they want to
establish and maintain
a balance between work and life?
These questions are
important to lots of people--
employers wanting to recruit
and keep young talented workers,
millennials like me who are
about to enter the workforce,
and hordes of consultants
giving us and business leaders
advice about the
changing workforce.
So let's start with
what our parents told us
when we were growing up.
My parents, like I would
guess many of your parents
if you're a millennial, said
that if I worked hard in school
and got a good education,
I would do well in life,
even better financially
and socially than they did.
But today, many
of us are worried
that our generation,
the millennials,
might not achieve that goal.
And if we ask young
people today if that's
what they really want
out of their careers,
we get different answers.
For example, the people who
took this course last year
said that their top
probability was addressing
big, important problems
at work, while also having
a sensible work-life balance.
Doing well financially
was also important.
But these data, like other
surveys of young professionals,
show that it's not at
the top of the list.
Hi.
My name is Eileen Rivera.
And I'm a third year student
at Wellesley College.
I'm also a millennial about
to enter the workforce.
And as you saw, there is no
one single most important
aspiration.
This extended quote from
a young woman in the class
illustrates how she sees these
different aspiration fitting
together.
"My dream includes
a job where I do
important work, something that
gives back to the community.
I dream of having a work-life
balance that melds together.
I hope that I'm able
to utilize technology
to make work more accessible
and eventually have the option
to do work from home.
I do hope to be able to find a
company that has a retirement
plan where the
company contributes
some percentage to the plan.
In some regards, I hope to
have some of the same benefits
that my parents had--
health insurance,
retirement plans, et cetera.
Most importantly, I want to
have passion for my work.
I want my work to help people.
And I hope to make
a decent living,
while making the generations
before me proud."
All this suggests that even
though our generation shares
many of the same concerns
of prior generations,
we care more about having an
impact and work-life balance
and money.
Our generation of
workers also looks
very different than
workforces of the past,
both in America and
around the world.
Almost half of Americans
today are people of color.
And many millennials
here and around the world
are children of immigrants
or immigrants themselves.
We will all be working together,
learning from each other,
and some of us will be
starting families that
blend our diverse backgrounds.
So we will want our workplaces
to embrace who we are
and where we come from.
But many millennials are
also having a hard time
getting started.
In the US, the
majority of millennials
say we are not earning enough
money to live like we want to.
More than a third of
millennials report
that we depend on our families
for financial support.
So many of us have to start
out in debt from student loans
and can't find full-time
or career-building jobs
in the fields we
studied in school.
How does all this affect
how and where we work?
Well, for one thing, we move
around from job to job a lot.
A recent survey said
people between age 22
and 32 change jobs between one
and four times in the last five
years.
And 66% expect to change jobs
again in the next few years.
Many of us are also
sending a clear message
that we want more opportunities,
not just for ourselves,
but for everyone regardless
of race or the income bracket
in which they were raised.
That's why some are protesting
against low wages of fast food
companies, racial injustices,
and income inequality
as seen by the Occupy
Wall Street Movement
in 2011 and by protests
of women and men
who are forced to
work in unacceptable
conditions in garment factories
in global supply chains.
What does this mean for
the next generations
of managers and leaders?
Sloan School MBAs who studied
data from last year's class,
concluded that as
managers of the future,
they will need to listen
to their employees,
engage them in solving
problems that really matter
to the organization
and to society,
and be flexible in
how, when, and where
people work so they can
be productive and attend
to personal and family affairs.
Those are the messages
sent by last year's class.
Let's see how this
year's class can
bring our voices
into the process
of shaping the future of work.